und jetzt meine damen und herren gleich
weil das hier raus was bisher also das
größte ist was ich glaube ich jeden eine
ebay mystery vox bekommen habe die
kapsel betroffen wären wir beim boxen
von ebay und ich bin kein sänger und
sollte das auch mein lieber lassen in
der tat und damit herzlich willkommen
hier heute meine damen und herren zu
einem video was auch sonst ich war mal
wieder auf die welt unterwegs und haben
nach ebay mystery box geguckt und habe
dort dieses tolle exemplar gefunden
mysterie boxe ich weiß nicht was für die
menschen los ist wieder eingestellt hat
aber er hat auch hier draufgeschrieben
mysterie weil sie nicht genau wissen was
eine mystery boxes das ist einfach
irgendeine box die von irgendeiner
person auf ebay eingestellt wird für
beispielsweise 25 und 50 euro 100 euro
und die person die die box einstellen
packt irgendeinen scheiß da rein und das
ist eine 100 euro mystery box mit dem
messer ich habe mir das hat folgen die
strengeren mein gott bin ich ein
vollidiot das hier ist das klebeband und
ich hab natürlich hier darunter dass die
pappe zerschnitten sehr gut bekam
[Musik]
was ist denn hier eine bombe drin ist
ich habe die ganze box jetzt auf
gekriegt das heißt meine damen und
herren es um einheimische tief im
glauben
das ist nicht wahr ich wollte nur kurz
gucken auf die box schon auf geht also
das ist ja hier ist und klappmechanismus
ob man nicht schon auf machen kann und
ich habe schon zwei produkte gesehen und
eins von diesen produkten dass das ist
ja immer mega krank aber ich würde sagen
ich habe da sieht man einfach blind rein
also ich hatte mal rein das erste drückt
was wir haben ist ein eine findet die
brotdose ja ich gehe ja auch noch im
kindergarten in der brotdose scheint auf
jeden fall irgendwas drin zu sein das
heißt wir machen die fotos jetzt einfach
mal auf und wieder gold das sie sind
allerdings nur diese goldenen
schokohasen noch aus ihrer kindheit
kennt also ich hab die früher auf jeden
fall kübels gefeiert immer da war
allerdings auch noch so eine
eine lederne servierte drin mal schauen
was das fühlt sich an als wenn ein stück
scheiße darin nur wenige minuten später
warum die war mysterie box hersteller
warum kauft man sich sowas und packt ist
da rein oder warum hatte man so was
bereits zu hause aber dankeschön für die
schokolade auf jeden fall ich greife
jetzt mal wieder in die box rein und wir
haben hier etwas lauschiges was ein als
es sind zweiter es anders machen kann
ist und diese tour zu harmlos und kunden
meine schwester hat davon kissen in
ihrem zimmer und das kann man auf die
eine seite irgendwie so machen dann sind
es total schwarz kann dürfen auch die
andere seite kann man so machen dann
sind die nur noch halb schwarz
ich könnte ich schlafe ich auch mal
anziehen
[Musik]
aber ich würde sagen wir einmal wieder
ganz tief in die box
wir haben sie ja etwas ich brauche das
sind süßigkeiten oder so und es sind ja
oh mein gott ich weiß nicht ob wir die
kennt vom frühjahr oder ob es die heute
überhaupt noch kids im supermarkt zu
kaufen
bei mir gab es wie immer beim einem
kinderarzt ja und diese hier
diese mandarin bonbon oder ist es
änderungen sind so krank
lecker ich glaube ich erst jetzt 1
[Musik]
waren die abgelaufenen allerdings kann
ich jetzt mal wieder blind in diesem ist
reelbox hier rein und als nächstes
produkt was ich hier drin das hindert
ihn damit ist die box ich greife da
irgendwie so drauf und dass er in diesem
schleims blech legen
das sind normalerweise wenn man sich
spielzeug kauft ist auf der rückseite
gegen eine erklärung was das ist eine
anleitung oder so hier steht einfach nur
das auf polnisch und russisch oder so
das ding heißt water fand das ist eine
wasser wurfscheibe nein man kann das
ding in wasser eintauchen dass ich voll
mit was man kann man es über das wasser
wie sandstein und das mit den stein hat
mich beispielsweise nie hingekriegt aber
das glaube ich aktiv sehen hier freunde
und ich kann es auch gar nicht testen
weil ich keine wohnung kein see habe das
war eine leiter freunde und bei 70.000
likes kaufe ich mir ansehen und
bestellen vielleicht auch mal eine 200
euro mystery box heißt deswegen hier ist
auf jeden fall negativ vielleicht wird
in zukunft irgendwann mal ein video
kommen allerdings will ich sagen wir gar
nicht mal wieder direkt an die mystery
boxen
das ist geil das ist das ist ein bambus
besser finde ich auch sehr sehr nice
würde ich allerdings nicht raus trinken
weil das hier oben das irgendwie ein
komisches material man muss hier direkt
seinen mund
und so habe ich bin eh nicht so der
kaffee fan allerdings muss ich sagen wir
machen gerecht wird hier mit dem
nächsten produkt und zwar hier
ich glaube du bist wie box hat eine frau
erstellt erstmal irgendwie so liedern
ist geschenkpapier dann irgendwo einen
kaffeebecher dann in so ein leader
fermino der mir geschenkt wurde und
jetzt sowas ein fantasy model dressing
ab 1430 katrin freunde also ich kann mir
wirklich sich herausnehmen kann die hier
draufklicken hingehe und kann diese
mädels irgendwie anziehen megacool
dankeschön dafür als nächstes gerade ich
mal wieder in die box rein ja was soll
ich auch sonst als nächstes tun mal
wieder einen goldtaler halt mittlerweile
so 50 von diesen teilen 100
[Applaus]
für vision ist ein film im film ebenso
ein film der ab 16 ist sogar so kann ich
sogar ein guter qualität auf einer
playstation schauen im mega cool dann
ist man dafür wenn ich mir definitiv
nicht anschauen und jetzt meine damen
und herren gleich mal das hier raus was
bisher so das größte ist was ich glaube
ich jeden einer ebay mystery vox
bekommen habe ich hab es nun schon
gesehen und zwar ist es dass hier ein
fucking savage poster ich weiß nicht
warum ich glaube der ist aus amerika
profico oder so er ist aus amerika also
hier ist alles irgendwie auf englisch
geschrieben profi cook heißt das ganze
ding hier
das ist ein xxl märkten thorsten
leistungs kann man da reinpacken
ich habe schon einen sein wird stößt
allerdings trotzdem krass dass in dieser
box echt mal dinge drin sind wie man
auch irgendwie in einer gewissen form
gebrauchen kann außer vielleicht einen
dress me up mädels eschenburg auf jeden
fall mega mega geil einfach einpacken
sandwich toaster freut mich mega dass
die oft sage ich eigentlich im megapark
mein bett sagt die ganze zeit ein mega
so er hat einfach so eine aussprache
fehler bei diesem wort
das ist auf jeden fall das was er bisher
war allerdings noch ein paar produkte
und zwar als nächstes haben wir hier das
hier eine beauty nächstes produkt hier
sind meine damen und herren sind will
löffel also wenn man irgendwie mal im
sommer im park geht oder irgendwie so
und sich vielleicht noch irgendwie was
zu essen mitnehmen möchte oder keine
ahnung was kann man einfach ein joghurt
oder irgendwie sowas macht
im sommer mal oder nice so bald nicht
geben als dass man sich im supermarkt
wollten sondern schade oder so ist apple
dabei mega cool also auch dankeschön
dafür
ich sage die ganze dankeschön dafür das
ist so als hätte ich irgendwie das
geschenk bekommen aber ich habe ja dafür
100 taten ausgegeben als pulver trocken
ist auf jeden fall ein bisschen wenig
auf sie drin ist mitglied des herrn wird
schoss dabei aber wir haben noch ein
paar produkte als ich da jetzt mal rein
und wir haben als nächstes ist das hier
ein super surprise ich dachte das wäre
ebenso eine hühnereiweiß sondern
figürchen drin deswegen was zum
zusammenbau und jetzt einfach dass und
das also drogen und irgendwas keine
ahnung express ein gentleman letzten
zeit die musikbox also wir haben als
dieses produkt asien
ich habe es nur noch nicht angeschaut
ich versuche es jetzt mal nur durch
fühlen zu erraten ich bin mir nicht
sicher was es sein könnte
also ich glaube ist ein flaschenöffner
es ist eine led lampe ohne schwarz ich
hab mir letzte schon gedacht immer wenn
ich meinem bett liege und aufstehen
möchte oder so muss ich mir jetzt
irgendwie so nach links gegen wohlen
lampe an machen oder so wenn ich die
hier einfach dann müsste ich die hier
nach der greifen und die erst mal suchen
und dann machen also irgendwie man es
auch kein großer unterschied nächstes
produkt das ich hier drin befindet ist
dieses hier
ich kann nicht erwarten dass es ist weil
es einfach eine box ist ein zauber bad
stein ich glaube diese ganzen sachen von
wegen badekugeln worden und so zu ganzen
trends sachen davon früher die sind
einfach irgendwie schon monate alte
jahre alt haben schon die personale dazu
videos macht doch jetzt habe ich so ein
ding tatsächlich mal deswegen habt ihr
bock dass ich dazu mal ein video mache
und dann ja ich habe auch keine ahnung
was ich machen soll allerdings frage ich
mal wieder in die box rein und wir haben
wir haben der meister
doch das hier mein gott wie in basel
jelly bean ich weiß ja was dran erinnern
könnte aber ich habe damals mit rewe
einen nicht lachen challenge gemacht und
ich glaube dass sie sind tatsächlich nur
gut schmeckenden e sind es doch nicht
also das sind halt so boden und auf der
einen seite kann sind liegen nach
lakritze schmecken aber auf der anderen
seite das stinktier oder auf der einen
seite nach art der bananen smoothie
allerdings auf der anderen seite nach
toter fisch und diese boden sehen dann
immer genau gleich aus und eine
schmeckten einen schwenk nach war
schlecht und ich habe mir damals so viel
dazu gemacht und das ist er hat
millionen von aufrufen ich glaube das
haben wir an die vier millionen auf und
vermittelt
auf jeden fall einfach mal danke video
da früher auch so krass abgänger im habt
ihr bock darauf dass das ganze eventuell
nochmal möchte vielleicht sogar mit drei
wieder schreibt man die kommentare beim
ich bin frosch allerdings meine damen
und herren war es das jetzt glaube ich
auch mit dem inhalt von dieser box wir
sehen hier unten dass sie wirklich nur
noch so goldtaler drin sind also dass
der komplette inhalt
wir hatten hier liegen solche schlappen
die ich gerade schon mal an hatten wir
haben hier irgendwas wo man mit etwas
wasser schmeißen kann wir haben bienen
basel wir haben ganz ganz viele von
diesen goldenen teilen da war eine
packung löffel trainer bernd schuster
wir haben eine dvd eine blu-ray und
nicht zu vergessen das 430 er sammle
fashion.de mädels at wenn euch dieses
video hier gefallen hat meine damen und
herren hatte ich mir eventuell mal eine
200 euro ebay mystery box bestellen soll
ich weiß es ist unfassbar batzen geld
ich habe glaube ich oft genug gesagt
wollen wenn euch das video gefallen was
dir selbst daumen hoch geben wenn es
euch nicht gefällt könnt ihr auch die
anderen unter geben kann auch sein dass
solche diese videos gar nicht feiern ist
mega cool weil ich bekomme sachen die
ich viel mehr geld bezahlt als die
sachen eigentlich kosten also eigentlich
voll die dummen ideen